الحياه في احضان الطبيعه حلم يراود
الكثيرين لكن هناك من انشاوا عالما طبيعيا
مثاليا خاصا بهم هنا في ويلز 30 حالما
وصلوا الى هذه المنطقه قبل اربعين عاما
وقرروا العيش فيها وتحويلها الى محميه
طبيعيه خاليه من التلوث مكتمله الجمال
للوصول الى هذه المحميه عليك ان تستقل
قطارا فريدا من نوعه قطارا جبليا
هيدروليكيا يعمل بقوه دفع الماء فقط هذا
العالم الخيالي تحول الى واقع حقيقي حيث
يرحب السكان هنا بالزوار من جميع انحاء
العالم المهندس باتريك واحد من ثلاثين
شخصا قدمه الى هنا قبل اربعه عقود لاعيش
في شراكه مع الطبيعه كان مسؤولا حينها عن
بناء المنازل واصبح اليوم مهندسا بيئيا
مشهورا
اعتقد انه مجتمع تعتمد اسسه على فكره انه
بات من الواجب علينا القيام بشيء ما تجاه
البيئه ما لم يكن مدينه فاضله حتى لو كانت
فلسفتنا دائما تجاه اسلوب الحياه في
انسجام مع الطبيعه انه مكان نقوم فيه
بالاشياء العمليه انه مكان للعلم
والتكنولوجيا بقدر ما هو تجربه اجتماعيه
وبيئيه
المحميه هنا تسعى للاكتفاء الذاتي مع
البيئه المحيطه كان هذا هو هدف المؤسسين
الاوائل الذين لم يبقى منهم الان سوى عدد
قليل
[موسيقى]
لدينا خزان اعلى التل يتم ترشيح المياه من
خلال الرمل والاشعه فوق البنفسجيه لازاله
البكتيريا ثم تتم اعاده توزيعها حول
الموقع من اجل الحصول على مياه الطبخ
والتنظيف او غسل اليدين وهذه الاشياء يمر
الماء عبر القصب لازاله كل الشوائب التي
كان من الممكن ان ننتجها ثم يعود الماء
الى بيئته الطبيعيه
[موسيقى]
السكان هنا يبلغون الان نحو خمسه عشر نسمه
فقط
يطمحون في النقل تجربتهم لاماكن عده من
اجل الحياه في عالم يتحلى بالمسؤوليه تجاه
البيئه
الم المسؤول
بيئيه سيكون واق
عنا يجب ان نعلم اكبر عدد ممكن من الناس
ونثقفهم ونلهمهم ونشجعهم على القيام
باشياء التي نقوم بها لاننا مقتنعون
باهميه ذلك
المقيمون هنا يتبعون اساليب خاصه للحفاظ
على الطبيعه الخضراء منها زراعه كل غذائهم
بانفسهم والطهي في منزل واحد للحد من
استهلاك الطاقه
احد المبادئ الاساسيه لاسلوب حياتنا هو
الاكتفاء الذاتي مع الحد الادنى من
التاثير على الطبيعه نحاول ان نزرع طعامنا
نحن نطبخ معا لان هذا يقلل من النفايات
واستهلاك الطاقه من خلال الطهي في منزل
واحد انها تجربه تعليميه حقيقيه لمعظم
الذين ياتون الى هنا لانها حقا طريقه حياه
مختلفه
في هذه المحميه الصغيره يتم الاعتماد على
تكنولوجيا الطاقه الشمسيه والرياح والطاقه
الكهرومائيه لكن مع الحفاظ على فلسفه
المؤسسين القدامى في الحفاظ على البيئه
[موسيقى]